في محاوله لتهدئه الاجواء بين البلدين اكد
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بين يمينه
النياهو خلال كلمه القاها عبر الانترنت في
قمه الديمقراطيه التي ينظمها الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ان تحالف بلاده مع
الولايات المتحده لا يتزعزع واضاف نتنياهو
ان اسرائيل والولايات المتحده عرفت
اختلافات في الراي من الوقت لاخر لكنهما
يحرصان على تاكيد ان التحالف بين البلدين
راسخ لا يتزعزع وما من شيء قادر على تغيير
ذلك وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اعتبر
ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه لا يمكنها مواصله
مسار تعديلات القضايا المقترحه معبرا عن
امله في التخلي عن المشروع الذي اعلن
نتنياهو قبل يومين تجميده في وقت لاحق صرح
بايدن بعد عودته الى واشنطن مشاري نص
القانون امل ان يتخلوا عنه مضيفا امل
يتصرف رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو على نحو يحاول
فيه التوصل الى تسويه حقيقي
وردنا على هذه التصريحات اكدنا نتنياهو ان
اسرائيل دوله ذات سياده تصدر قراراتها او
تصدر قراراتها عن اراده شعبها ولا تستند
الى ضغوط من الخارج حتى عندما تاتي من
افضل اصدقائها بينما قال وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي اعتمر وفقا لرويترز ان
اسرائيل ليست نجمه في العالم الامريكي وهو
يعني بذلك انها ليست ولايه امريكيه للحديث
عن هذا التضارب في التصريحات خاصه بعد
التصريحات التي تابعناها قبل قليل عبر
عوائل العربيه ينضموا الينا من اورلاندو
عبر سكايب توم حرب رئيسه حلف الامريكي
الشرق الاوسطيه للديمقراطيه ومن القدس عبر
سكايب الدكتور مير مصري استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه اهلا بكما
الاب مع سيد توم حرب هناك نقطه مهمه جدا
لم نشهد هذا النوع من التصريحات ان يقول
وزير اسرائيلي بان اسرائيل ليست نجمه في
العالم الامريكي في ظل هذا التوقيت هل
نتحدث هنا عن خلاف سياسي ما بين دولتين ام
بين ادارتين اداره التياهو واداره الرئيس
بايدن
اولا مرحبا لك ولد الدكتور مرسي
والمشاهدين الكرام
هو بالفعل انا بتصور هو بان ادارتين ماذا
تدير اذا ماذا تريد اداره الرئيس بايدن من
اسرائيل بغض النظر منفي السلطه في اسرائيل
ام غيره لان الهدف الاساسي من وراء هذا
التعالي في الاصوات اليوم وردات الفعل هو
ابعد مما هو القضاء التغيير في القضاء
الاسرائيلي اذا كان هنالك من اجراءات
للقضاء الاسرائيلي هذا شان اسرائيل فلماذا
اليوم الاداره الامريكيه تتدخل ولماذا
الليبراليه اليسريه الامريكيه تتدخل مع
الليبراليه اليساريه في اسرائيل ربما
لتحقيق هدف معين هل هذا هو الهدف اليوم
اللي هو تطويع نوعا ما ننتنياهو للسماح
للولايات المتحده بالعوده الى الاتفاق
النووي وهو ما لا يزال
العرقله الاساسيه في العوده الى الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران ربما هذا هو الهدف
الاساسي واليوم اداره الرئيس بايدن تستغل
الوضع الداخلي الاسرائيلي
لتغريدات عاليه الصوت وخاصه من
ضمن الاداره اذا كان هنالك من مجموعات
ثانيه في الولايات المتحده ربما هذا مفهوم
ولكن لماذا من اداره بايدن كما حصل نفس
الشيء 2015 مع اداره الرئيس اوباما في ذلك
الفتره ونعلم بان الرئيس رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو اتى والقى خطاب امام الكونغرس
الامريكي ولم يذهب الى ملاقاه الرئيس
اوباما في ذلك الفتره دكتور ماير هل تتفق
مع هذا الراي الذي يقول بان المس اله
تتجاوز التعديلات
القضائيه وان هناك ابعاد اخرى تتعلق بسلام
مقبل باتفاق نووي مع ايران وبعض
الاشتراطات التي تريدها الولايات المتحده
من اسرائيل ومن حكومه نتنياهو تحديدا
شكرا لكم على الاستضافه تحياتي لك يا
استاذي الكريم والسيد توم انا طبعا لا
اتفق مع ما قيل وربما هي هذه هي المره
الاولى التي لا اتفق فيها مع استاذ توم
حرب اولا دعونا نقول
قبل ان ندخل في صلب الموضوع انه صار
الكثير من التهويل لانه ماذا حدث العلاقات
بين اوشليم القدس وواشنطن هي علاقات راسخه
ومتميزه وكل يوم هناك المزيد من المشاريع
التي تتم بشراكه بين البلدين هذا الاسبوع
تم الاعلان عن اعفاء الاعفاء التاشيره
السفر بين الولايات المتحده اي انه للمره
الاولى في تاريخ البلدين الاسرائيلي يذهب
الى الولايات المتحده بدون فيزا وكذلك
الامريكي الى اسرائيل بدون تاشيره سفر
الوزارات العدل هناك مشاريع كثيره بينها
على المستوى الالماني والتجاري والسلاح
والاستخبارات والولايات المتحده قالت
اليوم اكدت على لسانك الرئيس بايدن ان في
علاقات راسخه وانها اسرائيل صديقه
الولايات المتحده وكذلك في اسرائيل
بتغريده انتظرت من رئيس الوزراء
في الاسابيع او الاشهر القادمه ماذا فعل
الرجل الرجل لا يريد ان هو حر لا انه
اسرائيل منقسمه
والحكومه اليوم اصبحت في وضع
انه شرعيتها غير غير مكتمله وبالتالي لا
اعتقد انه علينا ان نهول فيما يتعلق
بالصلب الموضوع وتعقيما على ما قاله
الاستاذ توم انا لديهم ملاحظتين الملاحظه
الاولى انا لا اتفق حينما يقال
بان الشارع الاسرائيلي
وهذا الحشد الشعبي الكبير الذي عذر على
التعبير الحشد الشعبي طبعا في اسرائيل ليس
في العراق هذا الحشد الكبير في في اسرائيل
هو يمثل اليسار التقدمي او الليبراليه
اليساريه هذا الكلام غير صحيح هذا كلام
غير صحيح اولا هذه ليست معارضه للسيد
يشكك في شرايتها ولكن هذه المظاهرات تقوم
بها احزاب يمين ليس فقط احزاب يسار حزب
اسرائيل بيتونه وهو يميني متشدد حزب امل
جديد وجميع اعضائه من المنشقين عن الليكود
شخصيات بارزه وزراء محضرمين في الليكود في
عهد نتنياهو حكومات نتنياهو المتعاقبه
فالسيد بيني بيج ان ابن رئيس ابن مؤسس حزب
الليكود رئيس وزراء الراحل السيد مانيدور
وهو كذلك وزير مخضرم هؤلاء يدعمون هذا
الحاجه الكبير لماذا لانه يعتبرون بان
الحكومه بهذه الاجراءات غير الدستوريه هي
اولا تخرج عن اطار الشرعيه حيث انها تتحدد
دوله تتحدد مؤسسات الدوله تحدد نظام
القائم
مره اخرى دكتور ولكن مهم جدا
نتنياهو في الشارع هو اليمين ضد حكومه
اليمين هل هذا ما يحصل بالفعل سيد حر
لا لانه هو لتعديل بالقضاء في كذا نقطه عم
بيحاولوا يعادلوا بان
اتفق مع دكتور ماهر انه طبعا هنالك عده
اطراف هي ضد هذا التعديل لانه في عده نقاط
مطروحه وليست نقطه واحده فقط وربما الشعب
ولكن اليوم نرى الحماس عند الاداره
الامريكيه والحماس عند اليسار الليبرالي
الاسرائيلي اخذ ذروته بالتصاعد الكلامي ضد
حكومه نتنياهو ولكن لماذا الولايات
المتحده تتدخل بشان داخل لدوله حتى لو
كانت صديقه هذا شان داخله ويجب تركه
للاسرائيليين بغض النظر اليمين اما اليسار
الاسرائيلي ليصلوا الى نتيجه واذا لم
يعجبهم هذا فهنالك انتخابات قادمه دكتور
توم تدخلت الولايات المتحده كما يقول
المراقبون بان هناك تحذيرات ما ان يكون
هناك خطر هناك حرب اهليه متوقعه اذا
استمرت تلك الاشتباكات الغير معهوده في
اسرائيل وبالتالي هناك مصلحه حقيقيه
للولايات المتحده من اجل التدخل في هذه
المرحله
انا لا اتفق به مع هذا الراي لانه في
مشاكل عديده بكل العالم والديمقراطيات
دائما تذهب الى تحديات عنا هون منذ سنتين
كان هنالك تحديات ضمن الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه وراينا بعمليات شغب وحرك مراكز
وكان هذا بدون شك الليبرالي اليسار يعني
الشعبيه على الارض لا تعرف ما القياده
العليا ان كان بانطيفه ام بلايرز ليحاولون
ان تكون حاليا في اسرائيل هو امر اعتيادي
لا يجوز الولايات المتحده تدخل في طيب
الولايات المتحده تدخلت بشكل او اخر دكتور
مصري هل سيؤثر ذلك على العلاقه بين بين
البلدين وهذا شيء مستبعد بكل تاكيد ولكن
هل سيستمر هذا الخصام ما بين
نتنياهو وبايدن
نعم هو خلاف
بين
الرجلين
ولكن مره اخرى هذا هذا لا يؤثر على تربيه
العلاقه الواقع يقول هذا السيد بايدن يقول
هذا السيد يقول هذا وبالتالي انا اعتقد
انه لا يجب ان نفعل من الحبه قبه ثم ان ثم
ان
الولايات المتحده لا تتدخل في اشياء
الاسرائيلي من وجهه نظري هو باب التدخل
الامريكي او باب هذا الاعتراض عما يحدث هو
اشاره الاسرائيلي يعني لو انك لم تكن هذه
المظاهرات لما
الرئيس الامريكي او مسئولي
ممرر
للاستقرارات او الاوضاع الاخيره التي حصلت
في البلد دائما الحديث بقيه ولكن انتهى
وقت بانوراما لهذه الليله نقطه اخيره
التحالف الامريكي شرق خاصه للديمقراطيه
والدكتور
السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه شكرا جزيلا
لكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]